MARIA:  93,000 OVERDOSES IN THE
LAST YEAR, THIS ADMINISTRATION
IS DOING NOTHING ABOUT THE
FENTANYL THAT’S BEING PUSHED
INTO THIS COUNTRY.
THEY’RE LACING COMMONLY USED
DRUGS, THEY’RE LACING MARIJUANA
WITH FENTANYL.
AND KILLING PEOPLE.
>> YEAH, I THINK WE SAW WHEN
YOU AND I WERE ON THE BORDER,
TALKING TO BORDER AGENTS, THEY
ARE NOT ABLE TO FOCUS ON
STOPPING THE DRUG TRADE INTO OUR
COUNTRY.
THE CARTELS KNOW THEY CAN START
RUNNING FENTANYL WHICH IS DEADLY
AS YOU SAID AND IS GOING TO KILL
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE.
WE KNOW THIS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION KNOWS
THIS.
AND YET THEY CONTINUE TO ALLOW
PEOPLE TO COME ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY IN DROVES AND CONTINUE
TO ALLOW THE IMPORTATION OF
FENTANYL THAT IS COMING THROUGH
CHINA AS WELL.
JASON:  TEXAS ATTORNEY GENERAL
KEN PAXTON ADDRESSING THE DRUG
CRISIS AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER ON
"MORNINGS WITH MARIA" LAST
TUESDAY.
JUST TWO DAYS LATER, U.S.
CUSTOMS AND BORDER HE PROTECTION
MADE A RECORD-BREAKING SEIZURE
OF FENTANYL AND
METHAMPHETAMINES, MORE THAN
17,000 POUNDS IN A MEXICAN
CITIZEN’S TRUCK.
THAT’S RAISING NEW CONCERNS
ABOUT WHAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING TO STOP
THE FLOW OF DRUGS INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
JOINING US NOW IS NEW YORK
CONGRESSMAN, JOHN KATKO, THE
RANKING REPUBLICAN ON THE HOUSE
HOMELAND SECURITY COMMITTEE.
CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US HERE.
I SERVED WITH YOU IN THE UNITED
STATES CONGRESS.
TELL US ON THE BORDER, KAMALA
HARRIS DOESN’T SEEM TO HAVE TIME
TO DEAL WITH THIS, THE PRESIDENT
HAS NEVER BEEN, BUT YOU’VE SPENT
A LOT OF TIME ON THIS.
TELL US ABOUT THE DRUGS AND THE
SEVERITY OF WHAT’S GOING ON
THERE.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN, JAY
SO.
LISTEN, BEFORE I CAME TO
CONGRESS I WAS A 20 YEAR CRIME
PROSECUTOR, PART OF THE TIME
SPENT ON THE BORDER GOING AFTER
THE CARTEL.
ONE THING THE CARTELS KNOW, WHEN
THE BORDER IS SECURE IT’S MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT TO GET THE DRUGS
ACROSS.
WHEN IT’S NOT SECURE, IT’S A
PIECE OF CAKE FOR THEM.
THAT’S WHAT WE’RE SEEING NOW.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT OPENED UP THE
BORDER LAST YEAR AND ALLOWED
PEOPLE TO COME INTO THE COUNTRY
IT WAS A BOONE FOR THE -- BOON F
CARTEL.
IT ALLOWS THEM TO CREATE
DIVERSIONS, SENDING 100 PEOPLE
IN ONE SPOT, THEY HAVE TO DEAL
WITH INFLUX OF IMMIGRANTS COMING
IN, ALIENS COMING IN.
IT’S CREATING A MESS IN THE
UNITED STATES ALL OVER THE
PLACE, OVER 100,000 PEOPLE IN
THE LAST YEAR DIED FROM DRUG
OVERDOSES, THE VAST MAJORITY HAD
BEEN LACED WITH FENTANYL AND
THEY SEIZED ENOUGH FENTANYL AT
THE BORDER LAST YEAR TO KILL
EVERY MAN, WOMAN AND CHILD IN
THE UNITED STATES SEVEN TIMES
OVER.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
AND GIVEN THE FACT THAT -- I
KNOW WHEN YOU SEIZE THAT MUCH,
THAT MUCH MUCH MORE IS GETTING
THROUGH.
IT’S A SITUATION THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS CREATED AND
HE’S NOT DOING ANYTHING ABOUT
IT.
JASON:  THE NUMBERS ARE
STUNNING.
YOU TAKE SUCH A MICROSCOPIC
AMOUNT OF FENTANYL, IT WILL KILL
YOU.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT 11,000 POUNDS,
YOU THINK THAT’S KIND OF A BIG
NUMBER.
BUT WHEN YOU UNDERSTAND HOW
SMALL A LITTLE DOSE WILL -- LIKE
YOU SAID, IT COULD KILL EVERY
AMERICAN IN THE UNITED STATES IF
IT WAS ADMINISTERED.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
LOOK, IN MY DISTRICT LAST WEEK
WE HAD 14 OVERDOSE DEATHS IN ONE
NIGHT.
JUST IN THE CITY OF SYRACUSE.
I THINK IT WAS FENTANYL LACED
MARIJUANA.
I’M NOT POSITIVE.
THAT WAS THE PRELIMINARY REPORT.
MARIA WAS RIGHT WHEN SHE SAID
EARLIER THEY’RE NOT JUST LACING
FENTANYL WITH HEROIN, IF YOU’RE
SMOKING POT YOU COULD EASILY
SUCCUMB TO POT LACED WITH
FENTANYL.
THAT’S WHAT’S TRAGIC.
THIS IS A HUGE BYPRODUCT.
WHAT PEOPLE DON’T UNDERSTAND IN
UPSTATE NEW YORK FOR EXAMPLE,
THE BORDER’S THOUSANDS OF MILES
AWAY.
REALLY EVERY STATE AND CITY IS A
BORDER STATE AND CITY NOW
BECAUSE OF WHAT’S HAPPENING WITH
THESE DRUGS COMING INTO OUR
COUNTRY AND THE ILLEGAL ALIENS
COMING IN THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
CRIMINAL TRAFFIC AS WELL.
JASON:  THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING, I
WISH PEOPLE FULLY UNDERSTOOD HOW
DRAMATIC THIS ACTUALLY IS
BECAUSE THE TOLL THAT IT TAKES
ON HUMANS AND THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING THAT’S GOING ON, I
MEAN, LOOK AT THESE STATISTICS.
THE STATISTICS ARE ABSOLUTELY
STUNNING.
THEY’RE OVERWHELMING AND NOWHERE
CLOSE TO WHAT WE’VE EVER DEALT
WITH IN THE PAST, CONGRESSMAN.
>> YEAH, YOU’RE RIGHT.
LET’S DO A LITTLE MATH HERE.
THE CARTELS ARE GETTING RICH TO
AN EXTENT THEY NEVER DREAMED OF
JUST BY DEALING DRUGS.
THEY CONTROL THE BORDER.
YOU CAN’T CROSS THE BORDER
WITHOUT PAYING THEM TO COME IN
FROM A HUMAN TRAFFICKING
STANDPOINT.
$4,000 IS A MINIMUM, OFTENTIMES
MUCH MORE.
MANY OF THE PEOPLE COMING ACROSS
CAN’T AFFORD TO PAY IT SO
THEY’RE TOLD BY THE CAR CARTELS
WHERE TO GO TO WORK OFF THE
DEATH.
WE ARE STRENGTHENING THE
CARTEL’S GRIP ON DRUGS AND DRUG
DISTRIBUTION NETWORK IN THE
COUNTRY BY HAVING PEOPLE COME
ACROSS THAT HAVE TO PAY OFF THE
DEBT TO THE CARTELS.
I WAS AT THE BORDER AT MIDNIGHT.
WHEN I WAS A PROSECUTOR, THEY
RAN FROM US.
NOW WITHIN THE NEXT DAY I GOT ON
A PLANE, LEAVING McALLEN,
TEXAS AND SOME OF THE SAME
PEOPLE I SAW THAT NIGHT BEFORE
THAT HAD COME ACROSS WERE PUT ON
THAT PLANE WITH A PACKET TELLING
YOU WHERE TO GO, WHAT AIRLINE TO
GO TO, WHERE TO GET OFF, NEVER
BEEN TESTED.
HAD NO IDEA IF THEY WERE
INOCULATED.
VIRTUALLY NONE OF THEM HAD.
WE HAVE ALL THESE ISSUES, PLUS
THEY’RE COMING TO WORK OFF THEIR
DEBT IN CITIES ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
IT’S CRAZY.
JASON:  SO THE PRESIDENT IS SET
TO CLOSE DOWN TRAFFIC FROM EIGHT
AFRICAN COUNTRIES.
BUT YOU GO TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER AND THERE IS NO SLOWING
IT DOWN AND NO COVID -- ARE THEY
EVEN DOING TESTING, LET ALONE
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
VACCINATED?
>> YES, THINK ABOUT IT.
1.7 MILLION PEOPLE, 1.7 MILLION
HAVE COME ACROSS THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY THIS PAST YEAR, SINCE
PRESIDENT BIDEN SIGNED HIS
ORDER.
1.7 MILLION.
VIRTUALLY NONE OF THEM, IF ANY
OF THEM HAD BEEN VACCINATED AND
THEY’RE NOT BEING TESTED IN
FACILITIES BECAUSE THEY DON’T
WANT TO TEST THEM IN THE
FACILITIES BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO
QUARANTINE THEM AND THERE’S NO
PLACE TO PUT THEM.
THEY SHOVE THEM TO OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS, WHETHER THEY GET
TESTED OR NOT WE DON’T KNOW.
WHAT WE DO KNOW LIKE I SAID FROM
MY PREVIOUS EXAMPLE, THEY’RE PUT
ON PLANES RIGHT AWAY WITH
AMERICAN PEOPLE, NOT KNOWING WHO
THEY ARE, WE HAVE NO IDEA IF
THEY’RE BAD PEOPLE, WE HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT THEIR HEALTH STATUS
IS, YET THEY’RE PUT ON PLANES
AND PUT ALL OVER THE COUNTRY YET
IF YOU’RE FROM CERTAIN COUNTRIES
YOU CAN’T COME INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
IF YOU’RE FROM MEXICO, YOU CAN
WALK ACROSS THE BORDER.
WHAT THE HECK ARE WE DOING,
JASON?
JASON:  THERE WAS A REPORT
EARLIER THIS WEEK, CONGRESSMAN,
ABOUT THESE AFGHANS THAT WERE
EVACUATED TO THE UNITED STATES,
SOME 80 PLUS THOUSAND PEOPLE.
BUT NOW THE REPORT COMING OUT OF
THE WASHINGTON EXAMINER IS THAT
THOSE PEOPLE WERE NOT FULLY
VETTED AS WAS PROMISED BY THE
PRESIDENT HIMSELF.
>> RIGHT.
THERE’S PARALLELS BETWEEN THE
BORDER IN AFGHANISTAN, BOTH WERE
ILL CONCEIVED IDEAS BY THIS
ADMINISTRATION WITHOUT THINKING
OUT THE ENTIRE PROCESS.
OBVIOUSLY THE BORDER IS WHAT WE
DISCUSSED.
AFGHANISTAN IS THE SAME WAY.
THEY DIDN’T THINK OUT THE WHOLE
PROCESS, THEY DIDN’T REALIZE
THEY HAD TO HELP PEOPLE GET OUT
OF THERE THAT HELPED US.
THEY CREATED THIS MASS OF PEOPLE
WHO RAN TO THE AIRPORT AND GOT
ON THE PLANES, MANY WHO DIDN’T
HELP THE UNITED STATES, WE HAVE
NO IDEA WHO THESE PEOPLE ARE.
I’M INVOLVED WITH REF FEW YOU RE
PROCESSES, THEY ARE USUALLY VERY
WELL VETTED.
THESE PEOPLE CAME ACROSS, THEY
RAN HIM THROUGH TERROR
DATABASES, IF THE NAME DIDN’T
SHOW UP, THEY WERE IN.
MYSELF AND OTHERS ON THE
HOMELAND SECURITY COMMITTEE ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE THE
GAPS ARE, THAT WHAT WE NEED TO
DO TO SLOW THE PROCESS DOWN.
THEY SHOULD NOT STEP FOOT IN THE
COUNTRY UNTIL THEY’RE FULLY
VETTED.
IF THEY’RE NOT FULLY VETTED, WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THEY’RE FULLY
VETTED.
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO KEEP THEM
SAFE AND WE’RE NOT DOING THAT
WHEN WE DO THINGS LIKE THIS.
JASON:  LOOK, THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AND THE
SECRETARY OF HOMELAND SECURITY
SAID ALL THESE PEOPLE WERE
VETTED AND THEY HAVEN’T BEEN.
NEW YORK CONGRESSMAN, JOHN CAT